[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  hmm  [Applause]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  uh  [Applause]  oh  little winds don't mean a thing  [Music]  [Music]  who says you aren't use his partner such  a  fool being so nice like her  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  um  [Applause]  [Music]  says  [Music]  little things don't mean a thing  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  now  [Music]  why just me  foreign good  [Applause]  [Music]  wow  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Applause]  oh  [Music]  easy peasy  [Music]  so  foreign  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  bye  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]  this will do for another month  thank you  this is wonderful  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you